but even doctors are lying to people now
saying oh it's okay to eat like
cheeseburgers they can't weigh you they
can't weigh you either even that and
it's like you guys why are you lying to
these people who actually some people
who actually want to be helped are being
lied to yeah oh just do the keto diet oh
just do the paleo diet it'll be fine
that's not a long-term Solution that's
not a lifestyle right doctors aren't
really even trained in nutrition they
don't know how to help but the business
model isn't set up for them to support
their their their patients
patients the whole model is flawed and
we really need to get smart and get
responsible and to be clear about what
we're putting in our thoughts in our
minds and in our in our mouths